dr marty mccary is a professor at johns
hopkins university medical
school of medicine and a fox news
contributor great to have you back on
the program
look i i know that we are following the
science and the facts
i i'm curious as to why the white house
looks like it's not and i say looks
because of the optics of president bide
well there's going to be a lot more
contradictions you know the public
perceives a low
risk out there in the community and they
are correct and i think what you're
going to see is more and more guidance
that's out of step
with the real risk level out there also
people are getting frustrated that the
goal posts are being moved
remember the outstated goal to get back
to a normal life and remove mass
restrictions was less than 10 cases per
100 thousand
half the country is there right now
harris about a dozen states have less
than
uh seven cases per hundred thousand so
when people see the goal post moved and
they see the cdc moving
two to three months late consistently on
every major issue the pandemic
there's going to be a lot of frustration
out there and political leaders are
going to need to respond to that
a wall street journal op-ed argues that
lockdowns didn't stop covid19 citing a
recent study that found
more virus spread inside homes than
workplaces
so we've known this all along but now
there's even more evidence of it the
op-ed is reading in part
there is little doubt that infection
would spread faster in congregations
than in smaller groups if both
engaged in similar practices but since
larger groups have an incentive to spend
on expensive methods of prevention
larger organizations might be better at
prevention than households
with fewer people dr mccarrick well it
raises a good point harris and that is
when you tell people they can't do
certain things and they need to stay at
home
people don't just stay at home and live
with their immediate family members and
not
engage in activities they do things they
do things differently
and they're more likely to do them in
indoor gatherings where they
may not be the same ventilation or
precautions or distancing
or mask requirements that you have at
the workplace so this is
study is telling us things we've already
known and rather than look back i think
at this point
we need to acknowledge we've made a lot
of mistakes when we told people to stay
at home
we should have told them to get outside
when we told people to wash their hands
like crazy we should have told them
to mask up at a time when the infection
risk was high
all right we'll move to this more
teachers are sounding the alarm over the
effects of remote schooling during this
pandemic and educators are now warning
kindergartners may never fully recover
from the learning that they have lost
one north carolina school district
official wrote this kindergarten cannot
be
replicated even by the very best
teachers in the virtual environment
a missed delayed or low quality
kindergarten experience
could impact this generation of kids for
their lifetime
dr mccary your thoughts on this and and
how the science really plays a part in
this how do we know this
well gosh this is really frustrating
because we know that the research is
finally going to catch up at some point
with the restrictions that were put into
place that happens after
every major natural disaster any major
event in the country
be it a hurricane or some major public
health crisis
we finally get the research that shows
that the restrictions or the
implications were far worse than we
thought we saw this after hurricane
maria in puerto rico
after katrina in new orleans and this is
telling us today the study
that we may need to change the curricula
that there's a year lost
you don't just make up for that and
maybe we need to start things off
differently
you know i'm concerned that in august
we're going to have a massive national
debate erupt
around a perception of risk even though
that risk is low
and that debate is not going to be a
healthy debate it's going to again
be allow our political influences to
come in
i you know yes we follow the science and
all that how about selling
it with the science and the facts so
sell them i mean do you why are we at a
place where people don't even believe
what they should believe because it's
right there and it's real
i think two things i think we have a
completely distorted perception of risk
right now if you look at covet daily
cases and new hospitalizations
we're about one-tenth the level of a
middle of a mild flu season
and the case fatality rate is similar
now that covet is in younger populations
we are well below the levels of a mild
flu season right now and yet the
perception of risk is disproportionate
also
if you dismiss natural immunity as we're
hearing from our public health officials
almost as a way to manipulate people to
say we've got to get to 85
vaccinations in order to have a normal
existence
that's ignoring natural immunity the
reality is nearly 60 percent of the u.s
adults now have been vaccinated
and about half of those unvaccinated
have natural immunity that puts us
around 80 percent
that's why the public perceives a low
risk in the community and they're
correct
well and the reason that that fits into
this conversation about children and
school and kindergartners in particular
and how much work we need to do
is because we anticipate based on what
you just said
there's no reason why we can't flip a
switch
and responsibly go forward in our
journey
get back to some things like school full
time so on and so forth expeditiously
a new piece in the new york times says
that many families are hesitant to
return to school dr mccary
because of the changes they've made this
year at home quote unquote teenagers
from low-income families have taken on
heavy loads of paid work
especially because so many parents lost
their jobs
parents made new child care arrangements
to get through the long months of school
closures
and part-time hours and are now loathed
to disrupt established routines
some families do not know that local
public schools have reopened in their
areas
because of language barriers or lack of
effective communication from districts
your last uh
word on this well i think there's an
entirely different perspective from
somebody who's wealthy who's got private
tutors who has a good
lifestyle during covet covet has been
good to a lot of people a lot of people
have been renovating their homes during
covet
but in inner city baltimore here it's
been a very different story remember
it's very hard to keep kids in school
pre-covet and covet has really distorted
that entire
ability to get kids in school and keep
them in school
marty mccary thank you very much for
your time your expertise
and your signs thanks